ドクター始めた野皆8皆さん金庫というものをご存じだろうかちょっと持っていきます
オーイングなんで買う機会合わないんです
ファンや政府ケースというものでございまーでもなんかマジで凄そうですよねこの人が
その近傍の凄さをすべて表しています
ドヤ顔でロングどんなものかといいますとまぁまさに金庫です j ぷケースという
わけで火災は貴重品や大切な
するよーございますかにあった場合あなたの大切な書類は大丈夫ですかそれでね少尉と
たを守れる金庫でござい
得るあと鍵がついてるこれが金庫です思う開いた
うわぁ中にこんな感じになっておりますの中にもの多いですねもう例えばこの映画も
市民の事故で数になってしまったと思った時でもこの中にあるものだけはしっかりその
から守られるという品に強い日んかでございますシンコって言うと金目のものも入り
から金庫した
今回私は思ったのだこの金庫外部の炎から中身を守るこれってなんて内部の炎からも
外部を守れるのではないかと言う
今回は内部で失い部で火災が発生した時ライブの世界を張って大丈夫なのか同額10件
をしてみたいと思います今回こちらにロケット花火700発準備しました音大はこの
緊張の中でロケット花火700発をぶっ飛ばして果たして
私の家は縁なのか動画を検証してみたいと思いますもしこれでな衣類の笠山もレイズ2
階4ダメだったらもうあれですよね自分が守れても周りの人は守れなかったら
素性はそこまでのを取ってこそ
気色中にロケット花火のラッパでていきましょうエッグさは
エックやサーバーやばいこれ大変やでもうマジこれやばいな爆発物の量が数は700発
連続とかタブー
ちょっとでもあんまりやっちゃいけないレベルだと思うそれを言えば中で気になって
なんていることでしょう幸せの絶頂ですは運 ki ジョブなんだろうがいっぱ
見えました
大丈夫だと思いたいよ大丈夫大丈夫多分大丈夫で今回なんですけどもこのロケット肌に
author キングの中でやれることなんてないと思うので中の映像を撮りたいと
思いましてこちらの中無駄に強い小型カメラを準備しますこれはこの中に入れて何度
この感じがキングの中で炸裂してる映像を撮りたいと思ったのでちょっとそれをの装置
を作ります大きめのペットボトルを準備します麻美
カメラが入るくらいの夫に切ります ok
花火が来ても音が入っているようなシールド発展中に入れておきたいと思います
多分壊れます育ち続けて危ないので安全な場所にいてやります
てろん
ネイル実際にやっていこうこれかつでちょっと取りたいんだけどだからすぐ ok ok
ってこんな感じでいきましょう
果たして大切なモノを守れる人のありの人も守れるのでしょうか
今映画を3
いっ
バーン
[音楽]
はぁ
持った
ていて怖い me
派遣まずここから開けるのセダンなどでは鍵を開けるのを開けるのを切るしかない
dee
キル
[音楽]
ran ん
ていた
re 掘った
n ああぽ
あっはっはー
[音楽]
ran
はぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああああああ
[音楽]
いいいい
male
re いっ
[音楽]
っぺ
voodoo